and if you clear the Sun yards in your
back it first down first down that's
quick yeah confusing you just got to
play it a couple times it all makes
sense
the [ __ ] they go from Pittsburgh caller
oh yeah [ __ ] farther this
okay throw everything buildings look
like a mirror shut up central browser
she'll be able to see mostly campus from
there
come ha bets just as your horses go
upstairs I don't know I guess yeah i
might as well check out with this stuff
is stay callous got a name is callous
anyways my fall you forgot to ask tommy
his name come on Becca it takes quite a
crude run that operation I'm not sure oh
well I like the idea stay with the horse
I'll go yes I don't want him running off
I'll be right back that's right thank
you okay spider says holy [ __ ] hey all
right
why are we in here again I know now is
that flavor yeah looks like someone
jerry-rigged this thing what the [ __ ] I
hear them let's just say elective you
all right hello juice see if I can get
the power back up let's fry these
[ __ ] okay so I'm gonna be find a lot
of people I guess
anything this way that looks like this
way is pretty clear let me load this
that one is that
see anyone cry ah [ __ ] upset hell that's
Bette's jealous oh [ __ ] you're gonna get
the [ __ ] out of here hi cat okay out of
my white [ __ ] out of my way aah chak
knock down a gut not to take a fight
this [ __ ] fight her yes a and that's
how we do things here that's that [ __ ]
that's that
now they're peg held oh ok let me urge
you to use this thing is that L the [ __ ]
is that don't [ __ ] here anymore so
okay okay triangles yeah I go and
triangle
that's a [ __ ] let's the hell's all this
about ok well im just gonna get out of
here then ok ok now let's see uh hello
I'll take this he says angle again the
bottom he Gondo see that fact yeah
mechanical triangle this patch
happen where when I was a kid I used to
want to be hey a singer think I hear
screaming those serious no I don't think
so Thanks happening scooch okay okay
yeah part of my pony shower now bats
come okay let's carry this any right
mess of them what the [ __ ] is that are
those monkeys I'll stay with callous
hate that name that's [ __ ] monkeys
I'm gonna shoot on these [ __ ] monkeys
how long we shoot comic con con oh it
doesn't let me shoot when they curse on
them all let me kill him okay I get go
back all right what's going on here am I
still speak on this run the center so we
should have a good look of things now
yeah hey that's right sure all the
monkeys first time seeing a monkey first
time seeing a monkey oh god here right
yeah school it's gonna cool though the
open exploration I can out of my way
yeah sure I'll go this way sure [ __ ]
refs getting tired I keep [ __ ] sloppy
maybe these guys like to keep a little
that's [ __ ] face at there ain't no
laughs here yeah all right let's try
that gate disconnect generator went not
on Teddy I'll be right back I'll be here
that's gonna not do anything but impress
it some of that give me some of that
[ __ ] can I do anything yet 50 50
anything good yeah what is this not sure
you find out where I am mush yet um my
prisoners getting slammed here must be
fought barricades let's see hit like
then
okay I don't know where the [ __ ] this is
I know it's gonna be some interesting
things here okay nothing quiche if I
take this I made anything yet now that's
sent here yeah it's good take this let's
sit here betch I'll take desk at since
journal
nothin I can't [ __ ] it wonder how long
you hail down that's it here yeah
there's a small [ __ ] room Jesus I go
out the window not see anything now how
does a hopping room to room taking that
[ __ ] that's kind of [ __ ] up yeah it's
it yet let's see here oh yeah bad day oh
yeah okay I love Jessica Jesus David
spores [ __ ] hater what is this oh
that and I great we all know what's
gonna happen here I just for the record
everyone say nothing shows up in the
spider-sense better
[ __ ] clickers all right the [ __ ] is
that big thing
okay I'm just gonna sneak by that thing
up on mines I hope you guys understand
that thing's huge
about to fight that thing hey I'm just
gonna fry this [ __ ]
Oh God God God God hey yeah dad yeah
blocking it I should old okay we're
gonna strain I [ __ ] it sorry I'm sucking
sorry I did take a little break to
squeeze a turn out and cut it up at the
dice worry more infected I'm fine come
up on the gate night I made that [ __ ]
guy dancing I have oh hey I thought I
out there that all know
hey hey
they're a cow I look at me a little
extra shin you know a little electrician
sure hope this doesn't make any monsters
appear that be [ __ ] up [ __ ] ok [ __ ] em
shut my deck hole uh-huh I can get this
guy let's try the gay feather gay [ __ ]
instead
yeah Gophers
okay critic was clutters I drew it off
nice no uh-uh why would they have it
affected so close to the lab now at it
is a former defense maybe they're doing
the same yeah doe je got it hmm ok room
scoot don't you get it and like there is
that laughs okay there is no free
manatee [ __ ] horse is like what are
we telling me College like I'm a horse
he's like I'm out or skies like what the
[ __ ] okay Jessica let's go sure faster
horse a faster kill me okay where is the
second year and it Marik laughs yeah I'd
expect to see someone by now stir sided
okay this must be a thing wait oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I would say come it says no
science lab sure yeah just seein a come
tough [ __ ] have you ever been to one of
these what university yeah not as a
student please reply huh uh I had Sarah
when I was pretty young what yo are you
married [ __ ] is that wow what happened
ok so much too much
this guy's horrible with his feelings
yeah that looks like a wet hen off the
horse eye out for this [ __ ] house
[ __ ] nice rusted shut or there's a
[ __ ] log on there maybe we can get
over it may be waking at all for it she
says I push it knock it over hmm oh yeah
I'll just take this tonight knock this
whole car down
all right I'll push it I'll shout get
the physics of this game is
look okay back on the horse site I know
what I had mine but it'll do yeah i got
like way to what he represented thank
you getting on wheres not that's not all
right horse a duck on i wear and you're
gone here now please don't i get on
there um [ __ ] are we going just thing I
not oh alright maybe somewhere it
happened maybe we gotta go here again
now what the [ __ ] down to this okay
looking around now there's power gonna
do there don't these pipes now let me
cries it I'd be so crazy all right
what's the plan la what's the plan we're
taking your lid on this shet
okay wait well they're like is that I
see beyond there now well I won't
probably hitting the stream and probably
like is this hey all right oh I get it I
get it I get it now guys now need to
worry Jesus not your [ __ ] working oh
how Tara okay out the way [ __ ] come on
up here and up here come on come on I'll
write you up there oh maybe I can't do
it from there getting some thought okay
out the way [ __ ] ah Jesus it's really
gonna stay behind me
Wow now you got power Oh what's gonna
happen here all right we're inside good
pitch out for Harambee